democrats lose their cool that's the
focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
so what does it mean today to be cool
well in 2012 democrats thought they had
the market cornered on
cool come on
baby don't you want to go
[Applause]
[Music]
name of glass
sweet home chicago
[Applause]
[Music]
oh they started their stuff and after he
left office the democrats kept returning
to their obama nostalgia to hit trump
what does it mean to be cool answer
adjective meaning composed
you ready we're getting the cue under
control relaxed never going out of style
the obamas have been the first family of
cool since 2009 the first father of cool
was just 47 years old when he took
office and he showed off how chill a man
from chicago by way of hawaii could be
and now with the decrepit biden in the
white house the cell gets harder and
harder
democrats are the party of the rising
american majority people of color
younger people you know the single
women democrats are the party of getting
things done could you say point to one
thing the biodemonstration or you
democrats in control have done to deal
with inflation
well i can talk about what i've done and
what i'm willing to do
oh kenya
but the polls show none of this is
working
biden is taking a wrecking ball to the
economy to our military into our border
his team of radicals is doing everything
possible to keep energy prices high
and to strengthen china's hand
and a man who needs a blue dot and the
easter bunny telling him where to go
doesn't exactly scream cool and the
future
the future now includes elon musk
running twitter
and it's where ron desantis stands with
parents and puts disney back on its
heels
it's where fox dominates the competition
and cnn plus closes a month after its
launch party
but the regime media if honest they're
embarrassed by their puppet president
they're even worried that conservatives
are becoming cool
new york times columnist michelle
goldberg she's conceding that the left
exudes an irritating progressive
sanctimony is grimly censorious and that
the cultural energy is on the side of
opposing wokeness
she goes on to quote author james pogue
who in vanity fair noted this new
conservative movement has been quietly
edgy and cool in new tech outposts like
miami and austin and in downtown
manhattan where new rightish politics
are in
and signifiers like a demure cross
necklace have become markers of a
transgressive chic
now where's my cross necklace there it
is
demure leave it to liberals to
misconstrue a crucifix
the fact is without the veneer of
coolness that the obama's provided we
all see what has always been true
in the modern era conservatives have
always been the real rebels refusing to
accept a cram down of policies and
trends that don't work now and never
worked before
after all you know who are the ones
rubber stamping everything the teachers
unions want
who are the ones giving big business
everything they ask for
who are the ones still wearing masks
outside because doctor focus he endures
them
and who goes along with whatever the
gender identity crowd demands
who reflexively jumps to defend people
like jesse smallette
to supposedly cool left that's who
they're the ones bragging about muzzling
mickey
last summer we removed all of the um
gendered
greetings in relationship to our life
skills so we no longer say ladies and
gentlemen boys and girls we we've
trained we provided training for all of
our our cast members and in relationship
to that so now they know it's hello
everyone or hello friends
hello friend
we are the ones though who knock
billions off disney's stock price
they're the ones who won't do anything
to fight for human rights except talk
about it but we're the ones who hit
china with tariffs
it's very uncool to punch down and
that's all they do
they wage war against small businesses
like cake shop owners with religious
views or health club owners who try to
survive the shutdowns
they target selfless nuns like the
little sisters of the poor
and they fire beloved beloved high
school football coaches who pray after
games
what do we do
we go after the multinational
corporations and celebrity athletes who
bully americans on social issues while
they make billions by sucking up to
china
we fight the censors at big tech and the
open borders anti-tariff cabal at the
chamber of commerce
some of the worst people on earth are
the westerners helping the ccp including
many in the old republican guard
but the new more populous conservatives
like tom cotton bill hagerty and josh
hawley they're not afraid to challenge
our own leadership on these issues
who out there is actually standing up to
goldman sachs and blackrock as they
build their portfolios in shanghai and
beijing
it's not the woke left i can tell you
that
the big banks selling out their country
and selling out freedom they're the
opposite of cool
and it's where the modern left is
celebs pretend to fight for the
powerless but the truth is they're owned
by the powerful
lebron james and china leo dicaprio and
his private jets
prince harry
and megan
opining about how grim the future looks
from their montecito mansion
it's not cool to give people awards
either for stuff they don't deserve
but that's what liberals do all the time
jon stewart received the mark twain
award for american humor over the
weekend
after recent performances like this
the problem with white people
america has always prioritized white
comfort over black survival any real
attempt to uh rep rep
repair
a ton of
that damage
reparation
sets off white peoples they're coming
for our alarm
oh my god that was hilarious
today's rebels are the high school and
college students questioning the
anti-american tribe that they're being
fed by radicals in the classroom and on
campus
do you think the media acted
inappropriately when they instantly
dismissed uh hunter biden's laptop as
russian disinformation all the mistakes
of the mainstream media and cnn in
particular
seem to magically all go in one
direction are we expected to believe
that this is all just some sort of
random coincidence
now those young people they're risking
their futures by just speaking out
that means they have courage
very cool
but the left has such an inspiring young
stable of their own future leaders we
have to admit like at yale law school
where they disrupt a bipartisan free
speech event
can i ask you all as you know yale has a
policy of freedom of speech
dumb is never cool but at least they
have the millennials and mayor pete
and we're about to take a test ride on
one of washington dc's electric buses
we're going to have a lot more where
these came from so i'm excited to see it
for myself
[Music]
okay good morning here we go it's a
really important part of how people get
through their daily commutes but it's
also a really important part of the
climate solution
that oozes charisma
but our future stars really are cool
they don't get standing ovations at the
oscars but they stand for basic decency
for mothers and for fathers
we believe
parents not only have a role they have a
fundamental role to be involved in the
education of their kids and that's how
it's going to be in the state of florida
of course it was cool when trump had the
guts to take on the powerful globalist
interest in his own party and trump
showed us that putting america first it
actually works
and despite the relentless attacks the
fraudulent investigations he expanded
the party with women and minorities
very cool
now with all the democrat failures
mounting with all the tedious lectures
by equally tedious personalities no
wonder young people are fleeing the
democrat party
this is what we did in the 1980s carter
had wrecked america and young people
just said no way to continuing this life
of decline
so we voted for reagan i even ended up
working for him
and even with shoulder pads and bad
perms
we were the rebels back then
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else